hello and welcome to our conference call
MBA admissions insights preparing for
your letters of reference and essays
thank you for joining us my name is
Allison Davis an associate director in
the MBA admissions office I'm joined by
Derrick Bolton assistant dean for MBA
admissions hi everybody in the next
thirty minutes we'll be talking about
what to keep in mind as you prepare your
essays and approach recommenders for
your letters of reference
we'll start by briefly reviewing the
requirements for both and offer some
tips along the way we'll also discuss
some questions that you may find useful
to ask yourself at this stage in the
process and how you might go about
answering them we'll wrap up by
answering some of the questions
submitted by you in advance all right
let's start with essay requirements and
tips the requirements word length
formatting etc for the essay questions
are all on our website and you should
definitely read all of them but it could
be useful to review the basics again
here there are two personal essays essay
1 is what matters most to you and why
this is a pretty fundamental question
that really invites self-examination and
self-reflection Eric Derrick what sort
of things are we looking for there well
I think when you when you said personal
essays you you said more than you even
intended to because they're not intended
to be professional and that you're
speaking about work topics but truly a
personal reflection on the people on the
experiences on the situations that have
influenced you and more important how
those have shaped your perspectives not
just about you know what your
accomplishments are what you've achieved
so we'd say focus on why rather than
focusing on what okay second essay
question is pretty broad it's why
Stanford and how will earn your MBA at
Stanford enable you to realize your
ambitions so what are we looking for
there
Derek you know and I think if you if you
look back you know over the decade or so
that we've been that have been in in
this 15 years have been in this role and
we used to ask a question that was
really specific
tell us about your short-term goals tell
us about your long-term goals why will
an MVA help you and then why do you want
the MBA from Stanford and over time
we've shifted toward a broader question
because we didn't want to lock
applicants in unnecessarily it wasn't
something we were using and assessing
some viability as candidates and so we
said what's a question that will
actually help the candidate and so we
want you to reflect on why you want this
graduate education and management how
it's going to help you in realizing your
objectives and really thinking about the
distinctive opportunities you'll pursue
at Stanford because once you get here
you get I think overwhelmed by the sheer
number of choices in front of you so
it's helpful to do some reflection
upfront I think I've even heard you say
sometimes students have actually held on
to their essays and posted them you know
on a mirror and that kind of thing but
I'm on the door of your room at Schwab
or at Highland Hall and you know every
day it's a reminder of why you're here
and what you want to take away from the
experience but I think that that gets
back to the point again that their
personal essays they're meant to be
valuable to the applicant who's writing
them you know there are no shortcuts
here and so you really have to to think
carefully about who you are about the
experiences that have shaped you and
about where you want to go from here so
in general I think our advice is keep it
simple don't overthink it be sure to
actually answer the questions we're
asking follow directions that sort of
thing what else well you know we're
talking about essays and letters of
reference today and at their simplest
form both of those are stories and so I
think what you're trying to do with the
essays is to tell a story that only
can tell you know it should be fresh
versus being packaged you you know what
I mean by that you know and we can tell
the difference when things are
inauthentic you know one of my favorite
alums Leo Lynn Beck always said you know
think of the admission process not as a
marketing activity where you're trying
to to look at someone and deliver
exactly what they want but to look at it
as an accounting activity where you're
looking inside and then trying to
express that clearly so I think that
that's a good shorthand for me a kind of
what the what the aim is of the essays I
hope that that candidates are reading
what we said on the website because we
we do encourage people to get feedback
it's helpful right to get to get a sense
from people who know you very well
on whether the essays are coming across
in your voice whether you know this is
the brother that I know or this is the
wife that I know coming through on paper
but I you know caution you to to think
carefully about the difference between
feedback and coaching can you say a
little bit more about that the
difference well you know I think
feedback is and you've you've done the
reflection you've done the thinking
you've put in the effort and you're
getting Sandi checks from people who
really know you to ensure that what
you're putting on paper is authentic
that it does reflect you right you know
that's that's a couple of times that's
one or two times that's not many many
hours of people giving you word smithing
and rearranging your your flow of your
topics and you know telling you what
Stanford wants that kind of thing all
right let's go on to letters of
recommendations again all the
requirements are on our website
including the questions that we are
asking your recommender so of course
you're going to want to take a look at
that there are two letters of reference
that are required the first one would
come from a current direct supervisor at
work or as we say next best alternative
there are certainly situations where you
may not be able to get a reference from
your current direct supervisor you might
be self-employed or working
family business or in a new position
where your supervisor really doesn't
know you well yet or maybe you can't
even tell your employer that you're
applying so if you can't get one from
your current direct supervisor what
would be their other alternatives you
know I think this is probably the most
commonly asked question at information
sessions and you know the the short
answer is use your best judgment because
you're gonna know far better than we who
are good choices to provide to provide
that insight but I would think if you're
working in a services firm it could be a
client if you work in a sales role might
be a customer if you have extensive
operations with with management it could
be a previous manager and direct
supervisor or a portfolio company it
worked with so menu work with that your
organization who has direct exposure to
you and who cares enough about you to
make the time to write a detailed and
thoughtful letter and but I think you're
trying to get as Alison said you know
the next best alternative means as close
to that current direct supervisor as
possible the second reference actually
has a lot of flexibility for you you you
really have four different choices here
for the second reference it could be
again another current another supervisor
or a peer and those could come from the
workplace
or it could be someone from outside the
workplace who's perhaps worked with you
or supervised to you in an
extracurricular activity and so you know
those four quadrants are which which you
have to choose from in general though
Derek would you say are we the strongest
reference typically come from the
workplace absolutely you know I think
again with with thousands of applicants
each person situation is unique but in
most cases what we've observed
is that the recommender who's worked
with you for 40 or 50 hours a week for
you know six weeks or six months or
three or four years has deeper insight
into your strengths and your areas of
development than someone who sees you in
a volunteer activity for a few hours a
week even if it's a sustained commitment
you just have to be careful and thinking
about those choices we are come on on
your side as applicants gonna reading
the application so you know it's not
that we're gonna look and say oh this
this really doesn't give us what we're
looking for but I do see finals every
year where I read it and say gosh you
know the recommender really loved this
person did let's talk a bit about how
somebody would go about choosing their
recommenders advice advice about that
Derick sure will this brings me back to
my point earlier that that both essays
and recommendations are stories essays
are stories that you're telling us and
recommendations or stories that others
are telling us about you the reason that
we asked for references in addition to
the essay is that others see things in
you that you may not see in yourself and
so it's really helpful for us to have
both those perspectives as we're trying
to understand you a little bit better
you can see exactly what we're asking
the recommender so I strongly encourage
you know anyone who's applying to go to
the letter reference page on our website
to look at the the traits the
competencies that we're asking the
recommenders to assess as well as the
three questions we ask them to answer
but I'd suggest you know someone who can
provide at a tactical level who detailed
anecdotes who can give examples who's
excited to write a letter for you and
will actually spend sufficient time to
write a thoughtful letter at a more
philosophical level you know I picked
someone who is in a position to to see
how you've developed who who cares about
your career and is rooting for you to
succeed I think sometimes as you're
approaching a recommender the
conversations that come out of
than asking them to write a
recommendation can can really be
constructive conversations in in a lot
of ways you know we one of the things
you hear a say Oh Alison you know this
but candidates may not we often say that
we're looking for candidates groom
success has been a byproduct rather than
a goal and that notion of by-product and
goal comes to mind as they think about
references as well because you know in a
lot of ways the goal of the
recommendation could be to have a great
conversation with your recommender to
talk about your experiences and to talk
about things that you've done well or
areas that you may need to grow and to
get that person's feedback on those
experiences and if that conversation is
a productive one for you and for the
recommender the byproduct of that is a
great letter of recommendation that he
or she turns in you know I think it's
great to sit down with your recommender
it's this is not an activity that I'd
say simply recommend register him or her
and then make sure the person turns it
in by the deadline no no I think you
actually do want to invest a little more
sit down over coffee or tea or champagne
whatever the situation might be and have
a good coaching conversation and I think
it can be beneficial whether or not you
even apply to business school what about
we often hear applicants worry about if
they approach the recommender at work
that sometimes the recommender will say
well why don't you draft it for me and
I'll sign it what what should people do
in that situation yeah I know that's a
tough that's a tough situation actually
when I was applying to business school
last millennium had a manager who felt
strongly that every every consultant in
the firm who asked him to write a
recommendation should draft it on his or
her own so it ultimately ended up
picking someone else you know the goal
here I'll reiterate is to get insights
about you from someone else and if you
were drafting the recommendation and I
think it defeats the purpose you end up
kind of doubling down on the things that
you already know about yourself whereas
the recommender should be providing
insights that may be new to you and
hopefully may be new to us
yeah okay let's let's move on to talking
about some of the questions that you as
prospective applicants might be asking
yourselves as you get ready to write
your essays and approach those
recommenders you will find that
answering these questions for yourself
now could really save you some time
later in the application process so one
question you should be asking yourself
is do I actually have time to do all
that thinking and reflecting and self
examining before I write my essays yeah
but I think there's no shortcut here you
know we were looking for a holistic view
of you the applicant as a person your
your values your passions your ideals
your experiences your hopes and your
dreams and our goal is to understand
what motivates you and how you've become
the person that you are today and then
again how Stanford can help you in terms
of realizing your ambitions and so I
think you just have to be prepared to
think a lot and then right and you know
for each person it'll be different for
one person it might be a morning run
where you kind of find some time to
clear your head for another person it
might be the subway ride to and from the
office but you know there there's no
shortcut here so you really do have to
put in that time to think
so Derek you talked about how the essays
and recommendations are stories so
another question people should ask
themselves is what is a story that only
I can tell mm-hmm and I think what makes
it a story that only you can tell and is
not the person or the event or the
situation that you're talking about but
how that has affected you and how that's
shaped your outlook your perspective
your choices so I'll reiterate you know
what I say on the road all the time
which is don't worry about standing out
you never know what other applicants are
sharing with us
I think differentiation occurs naturally
if you concentrate on telling us who you
are and no one can know that better than
you
what I see happen all the time with
applicants especially applicants who
have the fortune or misfortune of being
in large communities where there are
many people applying is that they will
lose faith in themselves throughout the
process and so start comparing my GPA is
two tenths of a point lower than hers
and you know he was promoted three
months ahead of me and it's easy to get
focused on all the little aspects where
someone may have done better than you
but we're reading the application
looking for strengths and so I just want
to reiterate that you know we want
candidates to really have faith in
yourselves have some confidence as you
go through the process think about the
essays as conversations on people well
the have confidence and faith in
yourself and don't compare yourself to
other people that's good advice not only
for writing applications but good advice
for life I think honestly I think the
application process if done correctly is
as great in terms of pulling candidates
up from I'm working so hard on their
daily goals and asking some more
fundamental questions that will be
helpful whether or not they apply to
business school so another question to
ask yourself is how will Stanford help
me turn my dreams into a reality mm-hmm
well I guess the key there is do you
have some some dreams you have some
sense of focused interest of what you
want to do after business school
I think Stanford is a really magical
place and if you come here with
something in mind you know you can take
advantage of all the resources of the
University from business school to
engineering or law or medical school
whatever it is to make your dreams
happen but you know have some ideas of
what what your best self would be after
Stanford and related goals for your
education here you don't need to make
them up by the way you know if you don't
have really specific goals there's a
reason that we could have put the goals
themselves that's kind of a tweet you
know kind of a text box in the
application whereas the essay is focused
on how you're going to maximize your
experience and make the most of your
time at Stanford okay
well let's move on now to questions that
the applicants I'm sorry that the
audience we hope you'll be applicants
but that the audience have submitted in
advance what kinds of information should
I be providing to my recommender and I
think that's going to depend on your
relationship with your recommender you
know I've seen candidates who provide
the entire application and essay to the
recommender and I've seen candidates who
simply sit down with him or her in and
talk through you talk through the
process you you don't have to worry that
every single part of your application
makes it look like you've been lined up
since birth to be admitted to business
school at Stanford right life is messy
we understand that not all of your
choices will make sense as you're making
them but our hope is again when you look
back on them you're able to to extract
some common themes and kind of connect
the dots as you look back but again it's
not not like you have to ensure that
every single thing that your recommender
says is perfectly aligned with every
single thing that you say so I don't
think you have to go overboard on
providing information but it can all
reiterate you know there's benefit to
you as an applicant from sitting down
and talking with your recommender was a
person who knows you well person who
cares about you and whose opinion you
value about your performance and about
your future is it ever worth it to
submit an additional letter of
recommendation beyond the two that we
asked for yeah well I'll say you know
you've been through our admission
committee discussions many many times as
we think about what the requirements are
for an application so we have asked for
two recommendations because we think
that is the most helpful across our
applicant pool we do however give
candidates that bit of flexibility on
what they're what they're providing but
it's a risky move right so you know if
you for example give us a third
recommendation first of all I can't
guarantee that it will read it because
it really depends on
when it gets submitted but let's say it
was you know submitted with your
application at the time you applied and
we read that well then the question from
the reader is going to be this is a
helpful recommendation or an unhelpful
recommendation that's helpful
then I'm gonna say why was it not one of
the two other recommendations if it's
unhelpful I may ask why is it submitted
at all and so you know it's not a
risk-free move because it does call into
question the self-awareness and judgment
of the candidate and frankly there's
also an issue around fairness you know I
kind of think of the admission process
it's almost like when you take a test
you know you turn the test in at a
certain point and then it gets graded
and then we set the curve and then you
get the grades back well you know
providing extra letters of reference is
in a way like giving someone a chance to
do extra work on a test or to change the
answers after spur and turned in that's
not exactly fair to all the other
candidates so you know we'll always try
to get applicants flexibility but I do
think that they have to think very
carefully and I should add that it will
certainly be added to your application
in terms of what do we do with it but as
Derek said it may not be read depending
on if we've already read your
application or where we are in the in
the process because again it's like
again it's like taking a test yeah once
the test once Durbin's grade your test
well we're not going to keep adding you
know letting you change the answers on
it after that right we talked about how
the second recommendation can come from
a supervisor or next best alternative or
a peer so dare can you talk a little bit
about what counts as a good
recommendation from a peer as opposed to
one from a supervisor and again we're
talking about that second reference you
know the reason that we we think appear
can be helpful in the first place is
that most of you will spend your careers
after business school leading without
Authority in a lot of cases you always
basically trying to to move the
organization or your department or your
team or whatever it is probably a level
of whatever your actual child
responsibilities or whatever your actual
title is and so peers are folks who
influence without authority right and so
someone who can give us insights and
what it's like to work with you very
closely you know elbow to elbow shoulder
to shoulder can be really valuable and
understanding how you will participate
as a member of our community which is a
very strong you know peer learning
community as well as giving assistance
you know areas where you'll want to
develop as a student and strengths that
you'll draw upon once you're an alumnus
or alumna okay here's another question
both of my supervisors speak English as
a second language if they're not able to
write as eloquently as a native English
speaker is that going to affect my
candidacy and short answer would be no
you know we are with apologies to vegans
looking for the steak sizzle if if it's
a real drawback for the for the
recommender and he or she could submit
the recommendation and have it
translated and we just would ask for the
original as well as the translation we
don't want the translation done by the
applicant by the way so someone else is
in a position to do that translation and
we'd ask for that person's contact
information as well then we are able to
to extract from recommendations you know
the basic premise that's coming through
the recommendation how the applicant has
performed what makes them or successful
in a role it really won't come down to
word choice or things that are
particularly nuanced is my sense okay so
it's really the content it's not the
syntax or those yeah just of it right
distal Derrick what's your opinion of
using an academic reference versus a
professional reference when we when we
think about references for Stanford and
we're looking at them as a way to
understand ways that you've been
demonstrated leadership and understand
your leadership
seneschal and so in most cases academic
references have not had the opportunity
to see candidates demonstrate leadership
the you know there again there are
obviously exceptions maybe you've been a
teaching assistant for a professor maybe
you've done a research project remember
her and so that that faculty member
would be able to to provide some detail
anecdotes or evidence but for the most
part you know when we see academic
references they tend to be very brief
they tend to be generic and it's sad to
say in a lot of cases they talk more
about the faculty member that about the
candidate if you were if you were a
college senior and you're applying for a
deferred admission then you know the
academic reference may be the only
choice that you have so we see them more
frequently for folks who are applying
for deferred for deferred enrollment and
in those cases obviously we know how to
calibrate them but just be careful you
know again this applies to anybody but
be thoughtful and careful as you're
thinking about your recommender to
ensure that he or she is able to address
the specific traits the competencies the
characteristics that we're asking on the
recommendation form and in the questions
again I'll I'll suggest looking at those
on the website before picking a
recommender because if we get a form
that says no basis for judgment for 85
percent of the things that we're asking
well that doesn't help you and it also
doesn't help us okay how about for
reapplication what's the expectation in
terms of letters of rec and essays I
mean is it going to seem weird that they
are what matters most to you which is
such a fundamental topic changes
significantly from the year before our
view has been that as a reapplication
you were evaluated on the basis of your
new application in the context of the
new app
and pool there our sister institutions
of ours that will say you applied before
you know tell us what's changed since
the last application and we don't do
that it always felt to me that asking
that question came from an understanding
that my last decision was correct so
please explain to me what's changed to
change my decision and you know the
reality at Stanford is that there's so
many qualified candidates that we're
simply not able to admit all the
wonderful people we'd like to admit each
year so I don't ever assume that simply
because someone applied and wasn't
admitted that that was the correct
decision or but there was something
amiss with the application all that to
say you can turn in the exact same
application in two different years I
think you could get different results
not because you've changed but because
the applicant pool has changed but if
what matters most to you and why has
changed dramatically over the course of
the previous eight or twelve months then
the topic should change and if it hasn't
changed then that should remain similar
to what it was I would definitely take
advantage of the opportunity to provide
updated references because my assumption
is most of our candidates most of you
are getting stronger with time as you're
building experience and exposure and so
recommender today would be better than a
recommender who had exposure to you 12
months ago so just making sure that you
take advantage of that I would add that
even if the topic is the same probably
your perspective on it has changed with
another year or two of life and working
spirit experience and as the coda I will
say that we do not compare your previous
application to your current application
so as the assistant dean of admission I
would look at both applications at the
point that the file gets back from
interview and that's not looking at it
to compare word for word what was this
application versus the last one but
looking you know was there some major
red flag that we saw the last time and
was it addressed this time but for the
most part you know
it's not going to make a difference in
my decision and I would be the only
person in the entire admissions office
who would have access to the old
application so it really is you know a
new application on its own merit in the
context of the new pool
okay how about client recommendations
for people in client service businesses
are there common mistakes or there ways
that they can be enhanced that
applicants should be aware of and I
think it kind of depends on the client
depends on how familiar he or she is
with with recommendations to graduate
school into business school in
particular so we have on our website a
podcast I think and definitely a
transcript of a podcast where we talk
about what makes some recommendations
things like what really brings a
candidate to life and so if you were
asking a client who this may be the for
whom this may be the first
recommendation ever then you might want
him or her to take a look at transcript
I think it would be helpful but I would
just reiterate to the client just as I
would reiterate to anyone else how
important the recommendation is in the
process and and it would be really
grateful to him or her for making the
time to write the letter there's so many
good questions here but I think we
really only have time for one more
should the letters of recommendation and
the essays complement each other or
should they emphasize different things
about the candidate I'll say there's no
should sometimes we see bekommen letters
of reference and essays that are
reinforcing sometimes we see were those
provide different insights sometimes
they help us reinterpret things we've
seen but you know it's always helpful in
in context and as you're looking at the
applicant holistic way to have those
perspectives well we're on the stout of
time if you didn't get your question
answer today please feel free to contact
our office by email or phone to ask your
question before we go Derek any words of
advice for our listeners today in terms
of the letters of rec and the essays
well first I'd say you're you're putting
yourself in a great position by tuning
in for the call today we have
information sessions on campus here at
Stanford on typically Mondays and
Fridays we have off-campus sessions
happening all around the world and
literally flying out at about thirty
minutes from New York will be hosting
sessions later this week and it'll be in
India next week so we have sessions
happening all around the world and our
goal in traveling to where you are as
applicants is to be able to answer
questions so feel free to to sign up for
those and try to come and meet some of
our alumni and students and learn more
about the about the program and about
the process I'll reiterate that
comparing yourselves to to each other
can be just bad for your career morale
as you go through the process we really
do look at every candidate asking
ourselves what are the reasons to admit
this person so it really is focused on
your strengths and so I'll reiterate to
you as candidates you know who cares
about the things that you're not so
great at we care about the things that
you are great at and please please tell
us about those your recommenders will
tell us about those and that's how we
make decision ultimately great advice
Derek thank you and thank you to all of
you out there for joining us
there are two more MBA admissions
insights conference calls coming up
being a great applicant on August 10th
and considering a joint or dual degree
on August 31 you can register for them
on our website an audio recording of
each of these conference calls including
the one today will be posted on our
website in the next few weeks the
current application is now available on
our website there are three application
deadlines September 21 January 10 and
April 5 as Derek said there's lots of
ways to learn more about our program and
terms of information sessions we do on
or off campus as well as on our website
you'll find videos of webinars and a
calendar of events and audio audio
recordings so we look forward to meeting
you either online or in person goodbye
for now thank you